[Music]
good morning John good morning John
Friday November 16 welcome to the Los
Angeles International Auto Show I'm not
gonna be able to everything in so let's
just get started that is a Toyota fuel
cell vehicle that we drove from Alaska
to America just with hydrogen now
there's no hydrogen pumps on the way
from Alaska to America but Canada does
allow you to drive around with big tanks
of hydrogen unlike America so they drove
up big tank of hydrogen around with that
car though that it could get to America
it gets about three miles on a tank of
hydrogen here's a viable choice for a
nerdfighter who isn't extremely wealthy
the new Toyota Yaris it's a pretty
little guy or girl maybe a girl on I'm
sure like connected bad now about that
other than that little bit pretty
displaying at this Auto Show
mostly releasing their gigantic SUV
apparently they didn't get the memo that
this is supposed to be the green car
Auto Show and never like walks Sequoia
Ford has some really interesting
environmental announcements at this
year's LA Auto Show
for example this wall that you're
looking at is made of recycled paper
their cars are made of steel and don't
get very many miles per gallon piers
towards actual primary environmental
initiative it is a hybrid SUV
it gets pretty good gas mileage soon
it's gonna be one of the only taxis that
will be allowed to serve people in New
York City here we have Honda's FCX
Clarity display which they are fairly
extremely proud of and all they should
be proud because they spent like ten
years and about a billion dollars
working on this car good job Honda but
they're not the only ones who feel sell
cars here at the LA Auto Show this my
friends is GM's feel cell offering
nothing more than a fuel cell in a Chevy
Equinox body but this is going to be the
first steel cell car on the road here in
California in New York and in DC it
doesn't have a deal pipe it has vents
here's one of the big stories about ACE
Auto Show it's Volkswagen spaceup blue
also a few Soviet Volkswagen said that
its kill cell technology is more
efficient and cheaper to produce than
both Honda's and GM's here we have the
Lexus hybrid drive it's kind of like
getting exactly what you went for the
Honda Civic except you get to pay way
more money now I know what you're
thinking Mercedes in green well they
have developed this new kind of diesel
engine that burns fuel basically the
same efficiency is a hybrid car they've
also mixed that diesel engine with a
hybrid cards will probably cost you
about as much as college of decided one
of my favorite things about Auto shows
is that everybody is walking around with
cameras so nobody really looks at you
that funny when you're walking around
talking winning a camera in yourself you
want I can show you a racecar racecar
there moving today Lovato shows is this
it's like hey this is what a car
looks like what's wrong with the car on
the upside and if you were wondering if
they weren't actually in electric cars
at the Los Angeles Auto Show yes there
are this car is made of plastic bottles
that's pretty cool
possibly the greenest car available in
2011 the really old where is it
they've taken it away and I'm frustrated
cuz I was gonna do my final good morning
John from the Volt final good morning
John from the smart car was good it's a
great car with great fuel efficiency the
Volt has the technology of the future
and the Volt is mysteriously not there I
don't know why they've hidden it but I
hope this isn't a shadow of things to
come and that's what it's like to be a
green geek at an Auto Show
you get free smoothies I think it's
important for me to not be afraid to get
excited at these things because it is
exciting but I also have to not be
afraid to be
jerk and not leaving going back to
Montana where I belong
this is definitely not where I belong so
say goodbye to LA and welcome to my
basement John congratulations on your
Australian Enki Awards or whatever that
was and I'm really sorry but there's no
scavenger hunt clue today and John I
will
[Applause]